Gareth asks I've read some theories that
HAARP can be used to manipulate the
weather is this possible yeah HAARP is
uh I'm a Healy high-altitude radio
engine always RIA
I always forget the acronym yeah there
are people who are sure that the
government is is is stockpiling aliens
and controlling everything about
anything we would ever think about and
they clearly never worked for the
government but as the level of
incompetence for the get efficiency and
inefficiency yeah
knows no bounds yeah it for starters
it's true that you could manipulate the
weather like they did during the
Olympics and China like it's not that
you can't manipulate the weather it's
that whether you would really have any
serious control yeah a lot of the
weather well weather happens in many
places and so it's it comes about from
the heat balance from the energy coming
from the Sun what it reflects off of
what it gets absorbed by what the up
currents do what the down drafts do what
the rotation of the earth is doing all
of this factors in and so I have not
been convinced by any of the reports to
suggest that experiments in the upper
atmosphere physics experiments yeah are
having any effect on our weather
whatsoever right and but it would be and
it would be tragic if we wanted to say
oh that's why it's getting hotter in a
world okay because there's some
experiment happening it would that would
be tragic because we would be missing
the 900-pound gorilla in the room right
and then but can you see that the carbon
dioxide gorilla yes yes the 900 pounds
of carbon dioxide gorilla all right uh
here's another question right I don't
think gorillas can weigh 900 pounds is
that true of you know the biggest one
I've seen so not 900 pound 500 pounds
yeah not 900 so 100 pound little pumpkin
I bet there's like a pumpkin that
someone is made with a gorilla like a
500 per every ever let holding a 400
pound um that would work yes that would
be in the roof which would also should
attract attention um
[Music]